welcome to the session on react GS and
today's session we are going to focus on
the objectives of why would you want to
use react GS as a technology to build
scalable web applications in today's
session we will also focus on the
component based design strategy around
react GS and how the strategy focuses on
reusability of building single page
applications which are lightweight
quickly loadable with reduced amount of
waiting and response time for customers
that would be accessing your web
application in today's session let's
start with understanding the objectives
of what we are going to focus on purely
we will start with what react GS is all
about will then get into discussing the
features of react GS will then move on
to the components that make up the core
structure of react GS will discuss the
various type of components will then
move on to understanding props effective
state management event handling and we
would close the session with event
binding so what is react GS all about
it's a trending technology that everyone
speaking about based on scripting and it
evolves around this new age term called
full stack web development that we would
do in today's digital world so react GS
is basically a JavaScript based library
for building fast and interactive user
applications for the web as well as for
mobility devices so it is basically a r
ad or a rapid application development
tool that will assist with quickly
setting up a pattern based application
that's discipline that's flexible to
change that's well designed so that any
change is coming from your customer can
be incorporated very easily and the
changes can be isolated to one small
section of the code hence reducing the
effort that would be required to go
ahead and rebuild and test the entire
application again for every change that
comes in why are the customers requests
it's again an open source technology
being based on JavaScript the very fact
that it creates a set of components
makes them reusable which means that you
can inject these components on the page
as and when required
and that really promotes the reusability
of the application in the design
react.js is also basically maintained by
Facebook curve and that is also what
makes it really popular amongst
developers let's explore some of the
core features of this technology
the first concept that we're going to
speak about of the first feature that
we're going to speak about focuses
around GSX which is a syntax extension
to JavaScript it is basically used with
react to describe what the user
interface should look like so by using
the GS X or the syntax extension it is
now possible to write HTML structures in
the same file that also go and contain
the JavaScript code but still ensuring
the right level of segregation between
the script and the HTML in order to keep
the code legible maintainable and
flexible to change the other important
aspect of react.js is the virtual Dom
the generic Dom is released by w3c and
is an API that allows us to create the
HTML pages react keeps a lightweight
representation of the real Dom which it
calls the virtual Dom which actually
wraps the w3c Dom API or the Dom tree
structure that exists on your HTML page
so manipulating the real Dom is much
slower than actually manipulating the
virtual Dom which is the wrapper layer
on which the react.js API operates so
when the state of an object changes the
virtual Dom changes only that object in
the real Dom instead of updating all the
objects and this saves a lot of time
because rather than actually going and
generating a full tree shake and
recreating the entire Dom tree structure
of the page
working at the virtual Dom has this
added benefit that react.js comes with
where it does not need to do a complete
Dom tree rewrite for any update that
dynamically you would want to do on the
page the architecture that react.js uses
in a model view controller based
architecture react sits at the view
which is now responsible for how the
application looks and feel in an MVC
architecture the controller will map to
the functional flow of the application
and the model will map data store or the
data mapping mechanism in your app while
the view works and maps to the HTML
template
that are rendered on the screen so MVC
is an architectural pattern that
separates the application into three
layers the model which looks at the
focuses on the data and the data mapping
the entity model the view which focuses
on the HTML templates and the controller
that maps to the functional flow of that
use case so the model would relate to
the data the view to the UI and the
controller acts as a super user and
allows us to transmit data between the
model and the view this makes data
binding a very crucial feature of react
GS and reacts one-way data-binding keeps
everything modular and fast so once you
have your data set up in the model you
obviously would want to take that data
and represent it inside the view
so this unidirectional data flow in
react would mean that when designing a
react app you would often nest child
components within parent components to
ensure you have a healthy and an
intelligent data sharing strategy so I
could have a shopping cart component
which would have a list of line items
within it and that would be an example
of a nested component sharing data and
information among themselves
next comes the extensions so react goes
beyond simple UI and has many extensions
for complete application architecture
support these extensions also would
provide server-side rendering and
support mobile app development and hence
react can also be extended with flux and
Redux among other third-party extension
API is that support this entire
ecosystem so the very fact that we today
built using the JavaScript language is
because we can go ahead and create
hybrid applications that can then also
be ported as installable apps on
mobility platforms the debugging for
react is extremely easy to do because of
the large developer community and
support with plugins and Facebook also
provides a small browser extension that
makes debugging for react applications
faster and easier to do coming to the
component sir which is the core aspect
of what react has to offer and it's very
essential that we build the right
component design in the application to
ensure that transmitting data and
the information flow between various
components is really smooth in terms of
its execution and it's well designed and
this is the crux of the single page
application that we designed today where
you really do not navigate the user to
different pages but you just inject a
set of components into the page and
remove them when not required creating
an illusion for the end user that the
customer is actually going and
navigating across different pages so
coming to components they are actually
the building blocks of a react
application that represent a part of the
user interface so if you look at the
Facebook website itself this would be
split up into different components so
there would be a login component that
would take care of the credential
management there would be another
component that looks at registering
users the company logo and the connect
and share that you see would also be a
different set of components that could
be injected hasn't been required onto
the page so the sign up the image
component the icon component all of
these are split into several small
sections of code blocks which can be
tested separately and then add it onto
your consolidated page so the components
basically promote reusability where a
component that is used in one area of
the application can also be reused in
another area with updated data and this
is what actually helps speed up the
entire development process in react
you can also nest components within the
each other for example in a ecommerce
application with a retail store I could
have a shopping list component that
could further have an eye a set of
products within it and a product
component could actually further nest a
product detail component inside it and
this is what and how the entire
application structure can be designed
with nested components the render method
is one of the most important and it is
in its minimal form basically a
component must define this method which
actually specifies how this component
would go and render onto the Dom tree
and ultimately the browser from passing
properties between components which is
again a very core aspect of react where
components would communicate with each
other by transmitting data in terms of
property
and a component can also receive props
and these are basically data points or
data values that are passed by the
parent to specify certain values from
the parent to the child component
components are further categorized into
certain categories that we are going to
talk about
so there are stateless functional
components and stateful glass components
now what do these mean wait for focus on
the stateless first now these are
JavaScript functions which basically
return a stream of HTML and they can be
contained in a GS or a GS X extensions
files then we've got stateful glass
components now these are regular classes
that extend the component class and they
must contain a render method that should
return a stream of HTML and again they
can be contained within a GS or the GS X
file so stateless functional component
would not really hold any state in terms
of data values and will just return a
static stream of HTML on the other hand
a stateful class would also do state
management by storing some amount of
data along with it and then bind that
into the HTML view which would be
rendered on the UI let's talk about
props or properties now components can
pass properties from the parent
component to the nested or the inner
child component properties actually help
making components more dynamic because
due to the data binding and the state
that the property is hold you can
actually flash certain amount of updated
values into the user interface or the
components that are being injected onto
the UI it sends important to define all
these props there are data types and
also they are default values props in a
component cannot be changed let's talk
about state management next which is the
value that most of the components would
hold at any given point of time when
your application is functional we are
back again to the Facebook landing page
where we see the login component and
let's consider a scenario here where
when a user logging into Facebook clicks
on the login icon without entering any
credentials so what would happen
obviously the login would fail and the
color of the login icon changes
a sudden alert symbol appears
instructing the user to perform a
different action and prompting the user
to first register into Facebook before
attempting to login because that's not a
valid user ID that probably would be
registered with Facebook now these
actions are facilitated by react with
the help of States and that is what
makes a state management a very crucial
aspect of the react framework so a state
object stores the values of properties
belonging to a component so if I have a
login component the current state of
that component could be successfully
locked in or denied login these would be
different valid states for a property
belonging to a component so this state
can be modified based on some user
action or based on some Network changes
so every time the state of some data
changes react would rerender the
component into the browser the state
object is initialized in the constructor
of the component which is a function
that automatically triggers when the
component is object is initialized the
state object can also store multiple
properties so multiple property values
can be assigned and this dot set State
is a method used to change the value of
the state object the set state function
performs a shallow merge between the new
state that you provide and the previous
state let's talk about event handling
now events are going to be the
notification or triggers or user
performed actions that would trigger the
state in a component to get modified so
every application revolves around
handling and listening to events in
order to do something else in response
so in response to an event you can
perform an action so event handling
which react follows two major
conventions react events are named using
camel casing rather than lower case so
camel casing would have the first letter
of the word in lowercase in the second
major letter in upper case with GSX
you can pass a function as the event
handler rather than a string so entire
function expression can be passed as a
parameter to the
handler and not just flat string values
so here if you look at the code you see
an HTML button on the click of a button
that's the camel casing for the on click
registration equal to we've passed a
function which is called disclaim
message which will be executed when the
button is clicked and that display
message plays the role of an event
handler now it's time to understand
event binding so along with the
notifications that you subscribe to so
that you would come to know where users
have clicked or what interaction has
happened in your component you may also
want to send get our information along
with this event so event binding tells
the browser which function is called
when a particular event occurs and what
kind of data you would want to send
across so event binding in B is
basically what you achieve and react
using these following steps the first
step is you would find the handler in
the render method by using a keyword
called as this so this is a system
defined keyword in react which is used
to bind the event handler inside your
render method the arrow functions in the
render method can also be used to do
event binding the arrow function is now
an ECMO standard which also makes it a
JavaScript standard and hence the arrow
function is very similar to the lambda
operators etc that you have in other
programming languages like C shop so
binding the event handler in the
constructor is also another step or
another mode via which the event binding
can be achieved the arrow function as a
class property can also be implemented
to do the binding let's move to a
hands-on demo to understand how do we
set up a basic application using
components using nested components using
props or properties understanding state
management and doing event binding and
event subscription to setup a simple
reaction application so let's start with
creating a simple demo on react GS and
we are going to create a simple
application that will connect to an
online music streaming service called
Spotify and we will call our application
music
so let's get started the first step is
to first get the node.js platform and
server installed to do that let me go to
google and let's just type nodejs and
here is the website noches dot o-r-g
there are two versions available the LTS
which is the stable version and the
current will prefer the stable so we'll
click on that and you can see we have an
option which is called save file the
moment this file is saved to the disk
we just need to double click on it and
keep clicking on the next button to get
it installed on our system and we also
have a documentation available here so
which explains most of the features of
the node platform and there are binary
is available for different Oasis Mac
Windows etc so you can select the right
witness 32-bit 64-bit and the right OS
and then go ahead and download the
specific version that suits your
platform and you can see here that there
are different there are also help files
available that will allow you to go
through the installation documents for
node.js installation on Linux etc so to
start with I'm opening up the command
prompt and here is where we're going to
call the node package manager using the
node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard node.js
installation we will initialize our
react application so we would say react
- app and we want to now go and create
an application called music app in this
folder so as a prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from nodejs store to our G the official
website just download it and install it
and that's when you open the command
prompt you file NPM which stands for
node package manager in it for
initialize react - app is a standard
keyword to initialize and create a
skeletal structure of a react.js
application and the name of the app is
music app so we'll hit enter we'll give
this some time and you can see it's
started downloading the core reactor es
libraries and it
attempting to create our application so
it's installing all the prerequisite
packages and scripts that are required
initialized and create a new react GS
application called music app now once
this application is created all we would
require is an online editor so you could
use an offline or an on-premise editor
as well so any editor of your choice it
could be at a more sublime text or
webstorm and for this demo we're going
to use Visual Studio code which is a
free editor available by Microsoft and
you can just google for which will suit
your code again this is not Visual
Studio professional edition etc that we
use for building our C sharp or MVC
based applications this is a lightweight
editor for building JavaScript based for
stab full applications so so while this
installs let's go and take a look at
which will suit your code so this is the
Visual Studio code editor and this is
the editor that we've installed directly
downloaded from Visual Studio code comm
and installed it and all we need to do
is open up this folder that would be
created with all the prerequisite files
in it we just say file open folder and
we would open that folder within our
visual studio code editor so we'll give
it a while until that application gets
generated and once it's created we will
again implement the component based
design and architecture and the data
flow between the components and we'd
also look at connecting to a live data
source which is Jason set of characters
that we would consume which is a restful
service the set of music tracks exposed
as a restful api endpoint by spotify
which is a premium streaming service we
will connect to that and we will look at
accessing some of the music tracks on
that website okay so we've got the
application created here so let's
minimize this and we'll open up our
editor or we've got to say is file and
open folder and let me go to the react
GS demo folder so this is the music app
that got created and that's exactly what
we're going to open up here so we'll
have ik
to that folder it's called music app we
select it and have it opened in our
application so you can see here we've
got a node modules folder this has all
of the pre-installed packages that make
up the react.js library we've got a
folder called public which will have the
index dot HTML file that's the root file
that will launch so this is the single
page application that we typically
create in react you have a single page
which on which we are going to load
multiple components so that's the index
dot HTML and then we could go and create
our folder structure currently if I open
the source folder we can see a single
app.js file and that basically is the
file that has the source code in
JavaScript for a single component which
we are interested in adding on to our
page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding CSS file and
then we've got the a public folder with
the index dot HTML file which is going
to be the root HTML file that launches
when we run our application so let's go
right up here and let's add a link to an
additional file so I'm going to link to
another stylesheet ok so we say
relationship is equal to stylesheet and
the type is going to be text and CSS and
we will reference a file called reset
dot CSS and this is a file that we look
at adding up later on it doesn't exist
at this point in time so we will connect
this and that's purely for styling
purposes so that we can have all of our
CSS Styles defined there next thing I'll
right click on the public folder we
create a new file we name this file as
reset dot CSS so that's going to be the
CSS file that will have all of the CSS
styling that we are going to apply and
I'm going to use a ready code snippet
for the CSS code so
let me just so I all I do is I'll just
go and pick up a ready CSS file that I
can just go and use if you look here I
have a set of CSS files that are created
that we just going to use within our
application and and that will avoid us
spending a lot of time on the styling so
that we can focus on our core concepts
which is actually learning how
component-based architecture works and
how do we set up components and have
data communication between them in react
so here is a file called reset or CSS
let me just fire up notepad and I'll
just open up this file copy up the text
here and I'm going to just paste it
within my reset dot CSS and if you look
at the code very simple it's all about
styling so we've got article aside etc
all html5 tags set up as display block
so they take up the entire width of the
page we've got some padding margin and
font size etc defined we've removed list
styling for the unordered and ordered
lists specifying the line height for the
body tag so basically just styling up
tables and so nothing nothing to do with
react here it's just about simple CSS
that we've added up and now we need need
to actually go in and dive into grade
creation of the components that we need
so let's right-click on the source
folder so I'll select the source folder
we'll right click there and that's where
we're going to create a new folder which
is called components ok so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold all of the components within it
within the components folder let me
create another new folder and I'm going
to call it app and this is exactly how
we are expected to structure all of the
code that we have now I already have a
CSS and app dot J's which are the root
components that were added by default
and all I'm going to do is I'm going to
move them within this folder called app
ok so there's a proper segregation of
responsibilities and all of the code
that deals with a particular component
is all added in to respect
the folders and this really improves the
maintainability of the application going
forward now we need some images and I'm
just going to make use of some set of
images that I have downloaded from the
web and here are the set of images that
I have so I'm just going to copy all of
them and we come to a music app and we
go into the components and app folder
and that's where we're going to add all
of the files and you've seen all of
those image files getting at it so these
are just icons and images we're going to
use for our music tracks inside our
application now let's move to the app
dot CSS file and this is where we've
actually got so the app dot CSS file is
the file that's going to style up the
all of the style rules that we've added
into the route app component and this is
what we'll have to revamp so I'll just
get rid of this code and we'd probably
add something for the body tag the HTML
tag and the root element let me say hash
root and let's set the height to 100%
coming to all of the HTML across the
page
we'll give it up on size of 10 pixels
and the h1 elements let me give it a
padding of 0.77 and 0 let's set a
background color give it a background
color I'll just select some random color
here that can be applied then we'll set
up the text alignment which is going to
be the center of the page we will set up
the font family the font family is and
this is part of San serif what else to
be add let's add up the font size 1.8
and also the color so again these are
standard HTML and CSS elements so
nothing really that has to be done that
is specific to react here so again we
are bringing in the highlight class so
there is a class called highlight that
we will create later in the H
EML view of this component and we will
set this to a red RGB component so
combination of 46 1 1 3 and 238 ok so
that's pretty much done let's move on
and also add up for the anchor tag let's
add up some text decoration and set it
to none so that the anchor tags don't
come up with those underlines and of
course we provide a color of hash so a
white color there now coming to the h2
element for the h2 element
let's have font family and again I'm
going to use so I'm going to use the
font family that we defined here bracket
and we change this to probably one point
five five okay now coming to the app tag
let me just save this and create a copy
of it there was some content that I did
delete and I can simply go and make use
of it so I've just undone all of the
deletion so this is something that I can
if I can use something I can just
probably use it from the tag below so
let me start with a height here and
let's say the height of the header is
100% of the apps are you not hit a
padding:0 17% 10%
17% the background and I'm going to
change that to background URL so the
background URL or let's say the
background image will have a URL
property okay and that URL is going to
be dot slash V G 1 dot jpg so that's the
image that we've added some in the
previous step let's also add background
size so we'll add background size and
set it to cover I'll also need a
background position that at the center
let's have background repeat' which is
set to no-repeat so that we don't have
the image in a grid format and they
and I would need this so let's take up
the font-family will maintain the same
font family let's use font weight the
font weight is going to be 500 and the
color is going to be hash so that's a
white color then we come to dot app dot
so that's going to be another class that
we are going to use dot but app -
playlist is what we're going to name it
and let me say that the display should
be flex flexible display and we will
justify the content to leave spaces in
between alright so that finishes that
bit and now let's write up a media query
for the responsiveness of this page so
this is media for only screen and max
width is going to be 1 0 to 0 pixels
okay and the class name that will
provide data is obviously a playlist so
for this screen size we would align all
the items to the center and we change
the Flex direction okay so we seem to be
good with the CSS for the app as of now
and that's the app dot CSS that we
created
let me save everything hey let's check
for any kind of additional so all three
of errors no errors now things are good
in the app CSS and it's time to move to
the next step of building this
application now we'll have to go and add
up the code for the app dot J's file so
let's dive into the app door GS file and
this is where we will actually need to
go and add all of the code that is
required for the app component so all
the code that's relevant to the app
component we are going to add up inside
this specific component itself which is
going to be obviously the app dot GS
fine so we have skeletal code which is
important importing the react library
and let me get rid of the
basic sample local will have a plot CSS
that's getting imported here besides
that a lot of other files that we'll
have to get in so let me import playlist
and this is these are the components
that will create as we go forward and
we're going to get this form the
playlist folder and the component the
file is going to be called playlist so V
that that then we'll have to go and also
import search bar so what we're
basically doing is we're going to split
this app into different components
there's going to be one component that's
manages the playlist of all the tracks
one component will act as the search bar
so that's the search bar component that
we're going to add so searching for
tracks will be managed by this we'll
have another component that will create
that will get imported into the route
app component which is search results so
this is going to display the record set
with the set of results as an outcome of
the search criteria so search results
slash search results and finally we'll
go and import Spotify that's the Spotify
service from so we'll create a utility
folder which will hold the code that
connects us to Spotify so that's what we
are adding up next so all of the imports
are done one component that manages the
search bar so that search bar search
results we correct the Spelling's there
that search results that Spotify and
playlist so that's done now let's move
on to the class that we're going to
create here so let's create a class app
that goes and extends react dot
component so that's going to be a
react.js component so that's a
constructor we discussed about props or
properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing we are
using the super keyword as a best
practice so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor and also
we pass the values up the chain to the
superclass which is the route component
class now we are going to initialize a
variable called state that's going to
manage the state and we are interested
in
tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we will show
that as an array the playlist would have
different names so we just call ours new
playlist that's the default name and we
will also store a list of tracks which
is going to be playlists tracks so
playlists tracks is going to be a list
of tracks and let's close this block
okay and this too is going to be
initialized within the constructor so
we've added here and now we need to do
the binding we discussed data binding so
let's look at creating a search variable
which will hold this start search dot
bind and bind to the context of this
very class so we are passing the this
pointer then we'll create another
variable called add track which to this
dot add drag dot fine and all this
functionality is what we are going to
add going forward so right now we're
just setting up the bindings then we'll
have capability to remove a track so we
will say remove track so remove drag
equal to this dot remove track dot point
and let's fix that so and all of these
two is going to be initialized as part
of the constructor so that's where we
are going to add it then we need to
update update the playlist name so we
need functionality that will help us to
update the name of the playlist so
functionally that helps us to update the
playlist name so they start update
playlist name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind and this
is the pointer that will pass I need to
save the playlist so this dot save
playlist equal to this dot save playlist
dot point and pass this and then I would
also need to remove the track that has
been searched for from the playlist so
remove track search with this dot remove
track search and
dot find and finally one last function
that executes all of these which
probably will find to find to this
context so all the declarations are done
in the constructor now we need to
provide the definitions for all the
methods that we actually have added here
so let me select this have inside and
let's start with a search function so we
define the search first
it takes some variable value that it
searches on and then I am going to say
Spotify dot search I am going to search
for term dot then and that's an
observable so the moment it the search
returns a value it's going to call this
callback function and that's when we
want to set the state and we're going to
set the state for search results to
whatever is passed by the system so the
search results are going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state now coming to the
add track method so let's scroll up and
we'll say add track and this will take
the track to be added let's declare a
temporary variable called Trax equal to
this dot the current state of all the
tracks that are there in the playlist
now if tracks start find I'm going to
call the find method so if we are able
to find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist then we
would not want to add it if it's not
there in the playlist that's when we
would want to go and add it the triple
equal to is an equality operator that
will check for both for watch mal you
match and our match on the data type as
well okay so if the track is already
saved to nothing if the track is not
saved just track the track ID because
that is the track that will have to be
added if it's not if it's already there
then just return if it's not there then
we've got to go to this variable called
tracks we will use the JavaScript method
called push and we will push the current
track into this Trax array and then
update the state so we want to set
State of the playlist tracks and this is
how your state management that we
discussed in detail is actually being
practically implemented here okay so the
track has been added now let's talk
about the remove track so that's the
remove track function and that's the
track that we want to remove so let's
let Trax equal to this dot state dot
playlist tracks lose the set of current
tracks that we have and let track search
another temporary variable equal to this
dot the current state of the search
results then let's take the Trax array
equal to track start filter so filter is
of JavaScript function that will again
allow you to remove a certain value
create a temporary variable called
current track use the lambda operator
and if the current track dot ID is not
equal to the track dot ID which means
this particular track is not there in
the list okay so you need to remove that
and again I have a method called as
unship which will actually get rid of
the track in the array and then we've
got two so we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take our track as a parameter okay here
we are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we give it
thus current state of search results and
then we are going to say tracks equal to
drag start filter current track current
track touch ID not be equal to the track
dot ID and then this is where we would
want to say this dot set state and we'll
pick up search results and let's go
and assign that to track so that's the
updated set of tracks after making that
change let's remove this and correct it
okay so that's fine
so the remove track Cup is now the
remove track in the remove track search
is now in place let's add the to these
functions which actually again takes
track as a parameter and here we will
say this start add track okay so it adds
the track and then it removes the track
from the search criteria so the search
component which is managing searching of
the tracks that will go and remove it
from there after adding the new track so
that's a combined operation we want to
execute then I've got update lay list
name which will take the name of the
track to update and this dot set state
the playlist name is what we need to
update with the name that is passed to
this function then we've got to save
playlists so here we let me create a
constant variable constants are
variables whose values will not
frequently change we will take all the
track you are eyes dot state thought
playlist tracks with B dot map create a
temporary variable called track track
dot URL so we actually want to go and
now save this on Spotify so that's a
reason we'll access
Spotify is safe playlist method they
start state dot lay list name comma
track you are eyes and if that is
successful we then go into a callback so
that's the callback anonymous function
where we are going to say this dot set
date and the playlist name that we want
to create on Spotify will be called new
playlist so that's the custom name that
I want to provide and the playlist
tracks define that ok so that's for the
update on Spotify now here is where the
render method is going to return the
HTML now this HTML is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
JavaScript and the HTML in the same file
so you can actually go and access the
variables you've declared in the script
directly in your HTML view and
synchronize and bind the data together
so it helps from a maintainability
perspective so even though everything is
in the same file it's well classified
and differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we say href is HTTP localhost so that's
the default server port on which this
application will run okay and we want to
give it a custom URL name of musical
file so the h1 terminates will then say
div class name equal to app within that
this is how we're going to inject our
search path that's going to be the
search path component injected here and
on search so that's the custom event we
will call a method called search so on
search we just call we bind to a method
called distort search then we'll open up
another div here we'll have class name
equal to half - playlist and if you
remember that's exactly the CSS class
name that we refer to in the CSS file we
have another component called search
results that we are going to inject here
and that's going to be search results
here search results will be equal to
this dot state dot search results so
that's how we can actually go and bind
so that's simple data binding the
component is going to be displayed with
the data bound and if somebody says add
if if I click on the add button for
search results movies so it will add
that new track to the playlist by
calling binding to the 2ds function and
it will remove it from the search
results text box then we have another
component called playlist and here the
playlist tracks will be bound to this
dot state dot playlist tracks ok so on
the top if you look here we started with
defining all the function declaration
Shen's in the constructor then we
provided the function definitions that's
how and this that we pass refers to the
context of the current component itself
so whatever you put into the app
component or into the respective
component those values will be then
passed out here to these individual
functions okay so that's with a playlist
couple of things we'll have to do is if
somebody changes the name of the track
so our name change is going to be
another custom event where we have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have removed functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this start to remove track on save equal
to this dot save playlist okay so that's
done and we close this
so we seem to be pretty much on track
the export app will make this all of
these functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide up in other programming
languages so that's done we've created
our app component now let's create
another folder under components and
we've got to define all our various
components here this folder is going to
be for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we add two files within it
the search bar dot CSS and another file
that we need here is search bar dot GS
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the CSS file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex direction should we call him we
want all the items to be aligned at the
center so that's a line item Center then
we'll add up padding so padding top is
going to be 6.9 for our DM and margin
bottom is going to be 6.33 area all
right now let's add up for the search
bar so that's search bar we'll add for
the input element we want
the width to be two eight seven pixels
the padding to be 0.88 zero the border
should be one pixel solid white the
border radius will give a slight rounded
edge to give a web 3.0 look and feel so
we will set up the border radius then
we've got margin bottom so we've got a
bottom margin that we want to add up
then we have color so let's add up the
color c3f so that's the color black then
let's add text alignment of center and
let's add up a font size of one area
okay so that's how we've set this up
let's add the search path input is going
to be so if someone focuses so focus is
the got focus if someone clicks inside
so the end user goes and clicks inside
the text box we change the outline to
none okay and so for the search bar we
are interested on input and if the input
is focus so that's the events that we
are looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor:pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
REM the padding we are going to set up
to 0.77 REM and zero the border radius
we will set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly well defined search button with
a nice little border let's also add
background color ash 1 DB 9 5 4 so that
gives me color then I've got my text
alignment let's set that to center then
we've got our font family let's set up
the font family to the same standard
font 80 and it's a part of the
sans-serif family then we will set up
the font size to zero point eight three
3r M correct this and finally we will
need transition so all of these are
basic CSS properties so that will add a
slight transitional effect with a delay
of that many milliseconds so transition
background color we've provided what
else
let me scroll up let's also provide a
border here so we remove in fact let's
remove the border we would not want a
border on the button that would look odd
so I'll get rid of the border and color
we will specify as per our standard
color that we've been using okay so
that's the color we've specified and
then I've got font weight of 500 finally
we will take the search button and on
the search button we will register for
the over event so if someone takes their
mouse over the button that's the over
the event in that case if he hover
around the button we would want the
background color to change so it will
appear to have a slight little glow
there a mouse pointer moves over the
button okay so that's the opacity and
the RGB combination so that completes
the CSS file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and get the
code in for our search bar component and
that's exactly what we are going to do
next so let's start with setting up the
code for the search bar first thing
let's go and import react from react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot CSS file then we
define our class called search bar which
extends react dot component we define
our constructor and we go and pass these
parameters to the base class we also
define the state we just need one
variable here which is the term to
search for in the search bar and then
let
say this dot will define a function
called handle term change which is going
to be equal to this dot handle handle
term change dot find so that's going to
be the first function then a function
that will do the searching for us which
is this dot search so that's the search
function and we'll have it bind to this
then we've got this dot handle enter so
the moment we enter into that search
text box and enter dot find this so the
functions are ready now let's go for the
first one which is handle term change we
will pass it a system defined keyword of
event this dot set state and for the
term we will use the event keyword we
will get the value that is there inside
that textbox the moment the search term
the user has entered changes so the
search criteria changes we trap the
updated value then in the search
function we will update the local
property prop start on search okay so we
access the on search and pass it the
updated term and then we got the handle
enter on which we are also going to pass
the system define event keyword so if
there's any data flowing along with the
event we are interested in it in this
case the data is the key code that the
user is pressing and if it is 13 that
indicates that's the ask a key code for
the enter button so if the enter is fit
then the user is completed entering the
search criteria and we need to start
searching and that's where we write a
render method that's going to render the
HTML view and we return the complete
view here so that's the view now that we
want to return let's say div class name
equal to search path then on the input
text box we will use placeholder equal
to enter song album or artist that you
want to search for on
change on the on change event the moment
the term changes we connect that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment keys are pressed and released so
on e up is where we would want to
connect to this dot handle enter Y and
this is race bracket that I left it up
here so in the render function we're
going to return a value I shouldn't
forget to export the search bar so
that's what I want to export so we've
exported that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written a div tag
here is where we go and close the div
tag we've added an input and here is
where I'm going to add a button provide
a class name called search button and
the moment the end user clicks on the
button we're going to connect it to this
dot search and we close the button tag
within the button tag search so that
completes the render function so in the
render function again let's run through
all of what we've written we started
with extending reactor component we then
added a constructor passing props to the
super class constructor we created state
we set it to a value of term and null so
the state currently we defined as term
then we said handle term changes search
and handle enter should be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes we defined search we defined and
handle enter we've also defined then we
used render render we said is going to
return to us the HTML that we've
specified okay we dumped all the HTML
that we want this component to return to
us so on change and on key up our four
two functions that are two events that
we connected to where we called handle
term change and handle enter then we
added a button where we registered for
the
event and connected it to this dot
search so all the three functions that
we are actually written so two things
we've completed now in the app class if
you look at the app class we've actually
defined a set of functions here that
deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks
removing tracks then we have created the
search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions and all the functions that
we defined we have taken care to
structure every component separately so
the search component is doing something
completely different which is managing
the search bar we have the core the root
app component in which we have imported
all of the other set of JavaScript
classes that we are creating and that's
how the entire application is now
structured so and that's the core
concept when you're working with the
react where you would actually have
every separate block of code or every
separate functionality handled in a
different component altogether so we've
completed the search for component as
well so two components done and two
components good to go so we've got to
start up on the next set of components
that we will need to build and the next
component is the track component that
will manage individual tracks so a new
folder a new file called track dot CSS
and track dot GS so that's going to
manage the tracks for us so let's start
with dot track we would say display is
flex a line items Center border bottom
one pixel solid RGB a 256 256 256 0.8
that's the opacity then let's come to
track action so we use all of these
classes when we write up the
HTML view will add a padding here of 0.5
we will set up a font size of 1.05 set
up a transition color of 0.25 s order of
0 pixel and a background color of algae
P a zero zero zero zero color hash so
that's the color that we continue to use
then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
glass we want GB values change to sixty
five to sixty five to six five five is
the last parent so that's the hover then
we have track information so track
information is the next class that we
are dealing with we will add the Flex
parameter first display legs and then
legs Direction is going to be column
let's have justify content set up as
Center and let's have height as 180
pixel so that's a track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we need a
margin bottom of 0.2 to yep finally
let's have track information and
paragraph tag will have the font size of
zero point eight three REM and font
weight of 300 and a color as well that
we add so let's add up a color here RGB
a to six 256 256 256 and 0.8 okay so
that's that's in terms of the CSS and
let's move to the track and we will move
into the JavaScript file so let's move
in
- so let me take what we added in the
search bar I'll go to the track dot GS
this will change to track dot CSS ok the
constructor this will change to add
track so add track change this to add
track this is remove track change this
to remove track get rid of this and
that's going to be the add track
function and here we are going to say
they start props so we'll modify this
this dot props dot on add this dot props
dot track and then we have the remove
track so that's going to be the remove
drag function this function is not
required so this dot props dot on remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called render action so this is
going to be a function that we are
defining called render action and in
this we'll just check if this dot
props dot is removed if this dot drops
dot his removal so in that case we would
want to return so this is a view action
method that we are adding which is going
to go and add this button with a class
called as track action that we've
already written the CSS for and this
button will actually get added wire this
render action function and this tort
removed track is what it's going to map
to let's close this this is going to
bind to this specific function so that's
a closing button tag okay so the closing
button tag is what we've added there and
the binding is what we have done to this
start remove track and we you
so now the render action let's also have
the return here and we just add up
button and this is going to add track so
you can look at how the component is
completely dynamic in nature so we have
two buttons that are going to be added
this button with a hyphen is going to
remove the track this button with a plus
sign is going to add the tracks and you
can actually see how simply it was done
in a render action function so the
render action function actually helped
with the checking that if on the value
of the props and if the user depending
on the action performed you will
actually be able to remove a track or
add a track from the existing playlist
okay and then the class name here is now
going to be track the class name for the
enclosing div inside it so let me get
rid of this the class name for the
enclosing Dave here is going to be track
- information within it will add a ch3
we bind to this dot props dot drag dot
name so the name of the track is going
to get found here then in the paragraph
we will find to this dot props dot track
dot artist and with some gap this dot
drops dot track thought so that's what
we've data bound to and then let me add
an iframe an iframe allows us to very
easily inject some content into the page
within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be HTTP open dot so here I'm
connecting to the Spotify stream Spotify
dot-com /m bed slash track and close
this so that's the Spotify stream that
we are going to connect to and this dot
drops dot track dot ID so that's the
track ID the width is going to be 300
the height parameter this the height
parameter is going to be 80 of the
iframe and the frame border is going to
be zero and we allow transparency so
that's the opacity we will say true
let's add allow encrypted media so if
Spotify has encrypted media that also
would be embedded here and we can also
have the title set to preview so that's
with the iframe okay at the bottom is
where we would want to so this could be
an empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here I am just going
to say they start render action so we
call the render action method which will
actually give us plus minus button to
add and remove new element okay and
that's what we can actually go and add
up there so let's check now whether all
that we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good in terms of the
track component now and we have all the
functions in place it's now time to jump
into the next component that we would
require after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list and that's going to
have track list
CSS and it's going to have track list
dot GS so that's the track list
component now which we are going to go
ahead and use and the CSS we don't need
much so let's just say it track list and
we just provide a width of 100% okay
that's all we'll need in the CSS so let
me add this in the sea
says file save this and come to e jes
file now which is going to have the
tracklist code that we will need to add
up so here again I am going to save
import react from react we'd also want
to import tracklist dot CSS and we also
want to go and get track because this
component is going to be made up of a
collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from track slash
track and we will define class track
list which is going to go and extend
react dot component we just need the
render method here because this just
needs to go it does not really have an
each state of itself it simply goes and
returns a list of individual tracks so
this glass name is going to be tracked
list and we will bind to this dot drop
start tracks dot map create attempt to
be variable and this will go and return
the track component which is going to
find two individual track data the key
is going to be track dot ID so the key
is going to be track dot ID and on add
on adding a new track we want to find to
this torch properties doors and we
already have on add define so that's
what we connect to we add up my face
bracket here okay and then we would also
meet is removal equal to this dot drops
dot is removal and the on removes will
to this dot drops dot on remove so
that's for the track removal and so
we've got our track list oh yes we'll
have to go and also close the div tag
correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go and export the track list so
we've got one more component done which
is tracked lists and let's move on to
the next component now so we've got app
which is route we've got the search bar
that takes care of entering the search
criteria we've got individual tracks
that are searched and will return and
we've got a tracklist that manages a set
of track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some set of tracks so
we'll add a new folder which manages
search results and this is going to have
search results dot CSS and it's going to
have search results dot GS okay so we
need a search results dot CSS and GS and
here in the CSS file we'll keep it
simple for the search results so we'll
say search results we will set up the
width of 50% we set up the height of
nine fifty pixels we will say overflow
why is scroll will say padding is 0.88
an EM background color will be RGB a 95
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of zero four pixels two pixels
two pixels ash and then let's add a
scroll bar so WebKit and M o z are the
constants specific to Mozilla and Chrome
browsers so they target certain animated
features etc or properties that are
specific to those individual browsers
that's the reason we use those constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes
with a max with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results with is
ninety percent with a margin bottom of
to REM okay so - so it's - web it scroll
bar zero pixel width and we've said
transparent background so that's that's
about it with the CSS I need to get to
the GS file now let's move to the search
results j s file and that's where we
will now have to go and add up the
component code for search results and
let me take pick this up from tracklist
add it up here this would be search
results and we need the results will
return to us a list of tracks so we'll
have to get track list this would be
track list and I'm just going to return
class name will also be search results
so that's the component and this is
going to export out search results so
it's accessible across other components
then we've got h2 with results let's go
and create track list with a set of
tracks and we will find it to this start
props dot search results and on the on
add we are going to find to this dot
drops dot on add so we already have that
so that basically completes search
results and that leaves us with the last
component which is going to manage the
playlist for us so we will add up a new
foods will add up a new folder in
components and that's going to be
playlist and within that we will have a
playlist dot CSS and playlist dot GS so
that's our playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is wheels first set
up the CSS that we will need to add up
to the playlist and I'm just going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that CSS here so that's just the CR CSS
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure CSS let me get into the
GS file and that's where we will need to
go and add all of our component mode so
again let me go to the track not GS the
track list rather let me get this and
add it here we'll make some small
changes this is going to be playlist I
need to import the tracklist because the
playlist is going to contain a list of
tracks this is going to be playlist and
let me here this will be playlist and we
leave this for later hey let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one function
that we will need here which is handle
name change you know if I need to change
the name of the playlist so handle name
change and that's exactly the function
that we will need to write code for so
that's the event and this dot drops dot
on name change that's when we will say
event dot target dot value so we get the
updated playlist name coming to the
render will now need the input input is
going to be on change equal to this dot
handle name change the default value we
have already provided with a hard-coded
value which is new playlist so that's
the default value if not provided then
we will just pick up the default value
then we
the tracklist so tracklist is what I
will add the tracks I'm going to find to
this dot drop start playlist tracks so
we are going to bind this to playlist
tracks and here we will say is removal
equal to true and on removes equal to we
will find that to this dot props dot on
remove finally we will need a button we
will use classname equal to playlist -
save that's what we've added in the CSS
click equal to this dot drops dot on
safe and here we are going to say save
to Spotify so that's with the playlist
and yes we need to go and export
playlist and not tracklist
now we need to do a quick lookup in
Spotify so let's go to this website
called developer dot Spotify calm and
one we suck once we sign in and create
an ID it takes us to our dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application the name of the application
will be music Oh file ok and we will say
that we are building some kind of
desktop app for example for which we
want to connect this to and we will also
need to provide so we will say next
refresh the dashboard so it's asking me
for a login so let me log in one smooth
so moment I login that's going to be
description and I say maybe this is why
I need it I'll say no not commercial
integration agree with the terms and
conditions and we will say submit and
that's the application that has got
created and now I can say edit settings
and the redirect URL here is what is
important so it should accept
connections from HTTP localhost 3000
that's the port on which we will host
our application
and we'll say safe okay so that's now
there's a client ID that is generated
here for my app which is unique so I'll
just copy that up let me come up to my
application under the source folder I'm
going to add a new folder called util
and under that a new file called Spotify
dot J's so we will start with the adding
our code to the Spotify dot JS file that
we've just created as a new file within
the newly created util folder the first
line of code is going to define a client
ID variable that equates to the client
ID that we will generate on Spotify so
this is going to be the Spotify
generated client ID which is a unique ID
associated for the developer to connect
to the Spotify API and we will look at
the source of that as we go through the
demo the next variable that we create is
the redirect URL or let's call it
redirect URI and that will equate to
localhost colon 3,000 which is the port
and we'll create another variable called
the access token let's also create
another constant variable called Spotify
and this will work like a function
expression so we will equate it to a
function called get access token and we
will say if access token is true then
return the access token
now let's declare a constant variable
called access token match which will be
equal to window dot location dot H ref
dot match and we will say this is equal
to access token which will be equal to
and we will give a regex expression to
do a pattern match ampersand so that we
can actually get into the URL and
extract the token information from that
and hence the pattern match is crucial
here another constant variable called
expires in match equal to window dot
location dot h left
match here we will read the expiry
information using another regex
expression from the URL ampersand as
trick so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and expires in
match in that case the access token
should be equal to access token match of
1 then we create a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say window dot
set timeout and we are going to say
access token equal to comma expires in x
thousand then we will say window dot
history dot push state and we will say
access token we'd passed the second
parameter as null the last parameter as
slash and close this and we will return
access token else we will say Const
access URL equal to HTTP accounts dot
Spotify comm slash authorize client
underscore ID equal to dollar client ID
ampersand response type equal to token
ampersand scope equal to playlist -
modify so we are actually building the
URL that will now get generated so we
will say modified - public and redirect
URL equal to taller redirect URI so we
are constructed the URL now that will go
out and get generated in the browser and
here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access you are l then
we'll add the search criteria function
which accepts a term as a parameter to
John here we will say constant access
token equal to Spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass HTTP
API dot Spotify comm /v 1 slash search
Western mark that's the query string
that we will add type equal to track and
ampersand G equal to dollar and we will
pass the comma as the header information
we will need to pass the authorization
where we will say that the bearer is
dollar access token dot then response
return response dot Jason dot 10 so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so Jason responds and then we
will say return response thought Jason
after that another then block so we will
now say Jason responds and if not Jason
response dot tracks in that case we will
return an empty array else we will
return Jason response dot tracks dot x
dot and we will pass will create track
as a variable with a lambda expression
and we will create a temporary JSON
object with ID and that's where we want
to associate track dot ID that was
returned as the search result the name
is going to be associated with track dot
name the artist is going to be
associated with track dot artists of 0.9
the album is going to be track dot album
dot name and the URI we will equate
track dot URI
so that completes this block will open
the next and we this will be the safe
playlist which will take the name and
the track you are eyes
here we will check if not name or not
track you our eyes dot length in that
case we simply return out of the court
and then we declare a constant variable
called access token which will be equal
to Spotify dot get access token so we
get a reference to the access token we
then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be dollar access
token and we create a user ID and now we
will return the fetch result where we
will pass HTTP API dot fortify dot-com
/v 1 slash me so that's the URL comma
headers will be the header information
then we call the den function declare
response as a variable use the lambda
expression and access response dot jason
we use the then block or declare jason
response here we say user ID equal to
jason response dot ID and then we return
fetch HTTP api dot spotify comm /v 1
slash users slash dollar of user ID
slash playlist so this is how we have
constructed the URLs manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable will assign method as post the
data is sent as part of the body and not
as part of the URL and as the body we
will say json dot stringify to convert
this parameter name and then we will
generate a response variable to response
dot jason and then we'll create json
response with the lambda operation we'll
create a constant playlist ID which is
equal to jason response dot ID we will
return fetch HTTP API dot
Spotify comm v1 users dollar user ID
slash playlists slash dollar again we
are constructing the URL so playlist ID
will be replaced here then we will say
tracks and close this comma and here
again we will say headers would equate
to the headers variable B constant
headers and this rows here everything
fixed now so here we're going to say
headers should equate to headers and the
method is going to be post and the body
is going to be Jason dot stringify you
are eyes track you arise and we close
this we close this block we close this
block and we close this block so that
completes our code of course one more
thing we'll have to do which is export
this class out
so export default Spotify and that
completes the code for the Spotify dot
GS which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
here is the client ID that will have to
exactly match so I'll copy this client
ID and provide it here so that's the
client ID that we actually need and we
could also store it out here so that's
the client ID and that's the redirect
URL that we've also defined there and we
just create an access token if the
access token is true we return access
token so the access token is something
that we are going to do a match from the
moment we try and connect with this
particular URL and you can look here
that this is the access URL that we are
trying to connect with ok with the
client ID and host fixed with the
redirect URL right and then I've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we
why did okay we try to fetch data using
the search term provided if you are
successful we get a response of the data
and accordingly we light rate over the
JSON response and get a list of tracks
out of it and do a mapping of this JSON
object to the track ID named artist
information album name etc and here just
like a data access layer very similar to
a data access layer we've got a save
function which will save this data to
Spotify as well so I've got a safe play
list and I've got search so these are
the two functions which will go and
connect to the Spotify service by using
this client ID and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of JSON data and will
then allow me to go ahead and push that
JSON data into our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so I'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and bring
out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens PowerShell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so I'm going to say node
package manager
NPM start to actually start up this
application so that's going to do a full
compile and so we will fire this up give
access so I need to grant access to that
port 3000 let's give it time to run and
that's the app now that you can actually
see here so this is the search bar that
we actually had okay then we had the
results we had the playlist now the
results is going to consist of a set of
tracks which are maintained by the track
list and then you can take individual
tracks with the plus and minus button
and add them into the playlist
okay so that's how it's typically going
to work okay so as you can view here I
am just going to search for an artist
and we click on the search button it
goes to Spotify tries to connect there
and says that I need to agree to the
terms and conditions and I've just
agreed to that so the very fact that it
actually gave us
a confirmation link the moment we tried
to connect and execute our application
that's proven after it actually went and
connected to the service there and try
to return a value to us so this is what
we did we just added an artist we said
search and you can see now it's
successfully connected I've got a list
of tracks available from this artist and
you can see the plus buttons getting
added on-the-fly
so that was the render action these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value so I can click
on this plus sign and you can see that
the track gets added to the playlist
okay as in when I click here so I've
added a couple of tracks if I go back to
my dashboard of my musica file
application and that I've created here
in the developers portal of Spotify on
developers don't Spotify com it's blank
so now I'm going to click on save to
Spotify okay and that clears the
playlist so let me come here and now
when I come out here we saw that it
actually got successfully connected out
here now I'll have to log in to so this
was the development app that we actually
created on the developers portal of
Spotify now we will go to Spotify
dot-com so I'll just go to the Spotify
website and it says do you want to
launch the Web Player and all that so
let me click on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist that just got added right and
there were four songs that had actually
added to the playlist and you can see
here those four songs have got added out
here okay so I can go here and I can
delete this playlist and say I want to
delete it okay so there is no playlist
now I'll go back here I'll add two
tracks and I will say save to Spotify so
that's how you actually saw that the new
playlist you can see the new playlist
has come back here okay and that's the
playlist the playlist has got generated
again and that's the new playlists that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created
and that indicates the connectivity that
we successfully created with this
reactor and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down into
components which is the search component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks then we created the
search results which will generate a
list of results which further contains a
track list and this is the embedded
iframe which gave us the response which
is scrollable here and you can see that
the iframes we created allowed us to
scroll this with this embedded web page
inside the iframe container so with that
I hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole finally we'd like
to extend a big thank you for viewing
our content and I hope this has added
value to your learning journey and has
been instrumental in supporting you and
assisting you with learning the right
skills and acquiring the right skills on
this technology to help extend and grow
your career path and your journey way
forward in the industry
thank you so much and a big thank you on
behalf of the civilian platform
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here